[Music]
hmm did Chris Rock really try to
highlight Rihanna recently at a party
wait you know he would not be the first
the story is floating around out there
Michelle Turner though went straight to
the source to get an answer I can't wait
to find out when it shall foul down and
why Chris just can't quit out of family
when they all sat down together to talk
about their latest project how did you
guys meet did you meet on Saturday Night
Live we met uh stand up I'm part of the
best comic just see tonight cuz I'm
black my father Dana phony said to me
Adam remember I want you to marry a girl
has the same belief as the family I said
that dad why should two marry a girl
thinks I'm a smart Rock was in LA and I
started getting on at the comic strip
and I should have hated them yes getting
spots but it was so funny I just loved
them so much love they start in eight
movies together and now they're back and
the Netflix original the week off Adam
is the father of the bride Chris father
of the groom and they come from totally
different worlds I never hit my children
one of the good things about not being
there Chris has also recently joked
about flirting with Rihanna and striking
out would you expect to happen
did you shoot your shot and she just say
what's up I think yes did you get
rejected by Rihanna we all realize
everybody in their own way has been
reject yes I got rejected by Jacob
if you could take em away - he'll come
back to it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]